think
of nothing
what do you see
you might imagine a vacuum a region of
the universe drained of all matter and
radiation
but go further
try to think of a true nothing
an absolute
nothing
this nothing is not just empty but
devoid of space and time themselves
given our everyday experiences this
is hard to imagine
but we have often struggled with the
concept of nothing
the biblical story of creation tells us
that in the beginning god created the
heaven and the earth
but what existed before god's creation
in a moment before time in a place
before space
the bible simply does not say
and indeed our scientific theories and
observations also tell us that our
universe has not existed for eternity
they tell us that 14 billion years ago
it had a beginning a fiery birth in a
male strum of particles and energy and
it has been expanding
and cooling ever since
so what
came before
cosmologists offer tantalizing
possibilities maybe our universe was
begotten from a previous existence part
of an endless cycle or formed in the
violent collision between two other
universes
but perhaps the most unsettling answer
of all
is that our universe was born
from nothing
and if that is the case
how does one get something
from nothing
is no electron as real as one or two
when electric or magnetic fields are at
zero are the fields still there
these might seem like strange questions
to ask but by the early 20th century our
notion of physical reality had become
somewhat fuzzy
the rigid clockwork universe of newton
had been replaced
einstein had turned space and time on
their heads with his theory of
relativity and experiments showed that
the world of the very small was governed
by a totally new set of physical laws
in the world of atoms and electrons
physicists spoke not of certainties
but of probabilities
probabilities governed by brand new
rules
the mathematics
of quantum mechanics
but this is not how we see the world
our macroscopic large-scale world is one
ruled by certainties by things by reason
and logic
nothing is nothing something is
something and when you put your cup of
coffee on the table it stays there
every time
yet the distant world of the very small
the world of quantum strange in which
something can be borne out of nothing
and matter can pass through mata has
more of an effect on us and the entire
universe
than we might think
to understand this we are going to go on
a journey across time and space from the
universe's first moments to its
far-flung future we are going to unpack
the meaning of quantum mechanics explore
its impact on the cosmos around us
leading us to the biggest question of
all
just where did
the universe
come from
[Music]
this video is sponsored by datacamp the
fun way to learn about data question how
much data is there in the entire
universe
7.5 octodecillion zettabytes
loads
a lot of the study of cosmology is about
being able to process huge quantities of
information and datacamp is a great
place to start if you want to become
data fluent from beginner to pro it uses
a gamified system to get you up to speed
with r python machine learning coding
and lots of other hugely important job
skills in our fast moving world in fact
there are over 350 courses to try out
one example that i've been playing with
has been its course on data
visualization with matplotlib very handy
when dealing with things as big as the
universe and as long as time itself so
click on the link in the description or
pinned comment to check out the first
chapter of any data cab course for free
unlock new career opportunities and
become data fluent today
[Music]
werner heisenberg had a nasty case of
hay fever as a young physicist he had
been trying to understand the rapidly
changing landscape of early 20th century
physics for months he'd been attempting
to piece together the seemingly
nonsensical world of the atom
he understood that in an atom electrons
orbit a nucleus but if these orbits were
like planets orbiting the sun the atom
would collapse in a fraction of a second
and simply cease to exist so what rules
governed the motion of electrons
everything he had tried failed as his
mathematics became unwieldy and unruly
and now his summer hay fever had hit his
head was becoming cloudy his nose stuffy
he decided
to escape
seeking sanctuary on the small island of
heligoland located in the north sea he
hoped the fresh salty air would clear
his mind
and it was on tiny isolated heligoland
whilst relaxing one evening that he was
hit by a revelation that totally changed
our understanding
of reality
[Music]
it had all begun in 1900 with max
planck's desperate attempts to explain
how hot objects glow
he knew that in hot objects atoms
jiggled and it was this jiggling that
produced the rainbow of colours he could
see in classical physics all possible
jiggles were allowed but to agree with
experiments planck added a new
unexpected ingredient
he restricted the jiggles so energies
were present in distinct individual
chunks
and in quantizing these jiggles
quantum mechanics was born
by the 1920s this world of the very
small the world of atoms and electrons
had become a strange and complex place
just like energy the orbits of electrons
appear to be quantized too existing at
specific distances from the nucleus and
in 1925 owen schrodinger wrote down his
wave equation to explain quantum
mechanics
objects like electrons were no longer in
a particular place instead they were
fuzzy and spread out
described by something known as a wave
function
heisenberg had been caught up in this
swirling heady mix of quantum theory
like others he was trying to bend
well-established rules to explain how
electrons orbited in atoms perhaps they
underwent a little oscillations
something heisenberg knew how to
calculate
however like all the temps before his
calculations failed to explain what the
experimenters were telling him
but in the cool fresh sea air of
heligoland
new ideas quickly crystallized
[Music]
he realized that we can never actually
observe an electron in its orbit
what we see are the emitted frequencies
of light as electrons from one orbit to
another
so why bother trying to calculate the
details of the orbit
he decided what we should calculate is
what we can actually observe in our
experiments
heisenberg began working through the
mathematics ignoring how the electron
was precisely moving and it was then
things came into stark clarity
his new mathematics worked
the form of the equations in front of
him seemed strange but a mathematician
would have recognized them as matrices
whilst these are common in physics today
there was still a novelty in the 1920s
heisenberg did not sleep that night
instead setting off on a pre-dawn walk
he sat and watched the first rays of the
sun peek over the horizon from a rocky
outcrop on the island
as the day warmed he realized he had a
new mathematical way of explaining the
world of the very small
but what a bizarre world he had found
[Music]
heisenberg's mathematics tallied with
schrodinger's they did not talk of where
an electron is
only where it might be and when it came
to an electron's speed the description
is equally vague
how an electron jumps from one orbit to
the next was unknowable just the energy
emitted when it did so and it didn't
talk about the precise time the electron
would make such a quantum jump just the
chances of the jump occurring the
quantum world was not a work of
precision
the quantum world was one
of probabilities
staring at his equations heisenberg
realized the vagueness in position and
speed were in fact related he saw that
the more accurately we can discern the
position the less certain we are of
speed and if we try to accurately
determine speed the position is fuzzier
imagine you put an electron in a tiny
box
in the classical world the electron
would happily rattle around bouncing off
the walls if you cool the electron it
will move slower and slower eventually
you can cool the electron to absolute
zero and it would sit at rest not moving
but heisenberg's uncertainty principle
means that in quantum mechanics
this
is strictly forbidden as we know where
the electron is confined within the
walls of the box there is a fuzzy limit
to what we can know of its speed
no matter what we do quantum physics
prevents us from cooling an electron
down to absolute zero
try as we might there will always be
some residual jiggling
on top of this like position and
velocity energy and time are not precise
things in quantum physics and like
position and velocity how well you can
determine one is related to how you
determine the other the energy of things
can fluctuate over time with small
quantities appearing and disappearing on
tiny time scales and very briefly
breaking the law of conservation of
energy
this means that even empty space jiggles
a residual energy in the vacuum that is
always there
known as the quantum vacuum this fills
the entire universe as virtual particles
flicker in and out of existence
and so in the quantum world
empty space
is not really empty
nothing
it turns out
is something
heisenberg's uncertainty principle is a
fundamental law of the universe and yet
it seems disconnected from our
large-scale reality but as we will see
on the next stage of our journey the
physics of the very tiny does have big
implications for the cosmos
from our very existence
to the birth of the universe itself
to understand quantum mechanics role in
the universe
we are going to have to think about
our sun
for many years of human history the sun
was a god to the ancient egyptians the
son was ra king of all gods and father
of creation to the greeks he was helios
who rode his chariot daily across the
sky
but what
powered the sun
was it just a flaming ball like the
fires on earth
it wasn't until the mid-1800s that
science started to provide answers
and it started with lord kelvin
determiner of absolute zero and after
whom the units of temperature are named
he was considering just how old the sun
was
with the physics of the day kelvin
deduced that our star was an immense
ball of hot gas squeezed to high
temperatures by its own gravity and
there was only so much mass in the sun
to maintain it
it seems on the whole most probable that
the sun has not illuminated the earth
for a hundred million years and almost
certain that he has not done so for 500
million years as for the future we may
say with equal certainty that
inhabitants of the earth cannot continue
to enjoy the light and heat essential to
their life for many millions of years
longer and less sources now unknown to
us are prepared in the great storehouse
of creation
this estimate dismayed geologists and
biologists it simply left too little
time for the weathering of continents or
evolution of animals but lord kelvin did
not know
about the physics
of the nucleus
by the 20th century physicists had
realized that atoms had a definite
structure the negatively charged
electrons orbit a nucleus composed of
positive protons and neutral neutrons
but the atomic nucleus is tiny thousands
of times smaller than the atom itself so
an immense force must be present to
counter the mutual repulsion of protons
crammed into the tiny nuclear volume
unimaginatively physicists call this the
strong force
and if this force could be tapped in
nuclear reactions
energy would be unleashed
soon experimenters were crashing atoms
together and outpoured copious energy
eventually in 1920 cambridge astronomer
arthur eddington put two and two
together he decided the power of stars
lay within the nuclei of atoms
stars including our sun are mainly
hydrogen the simplest element in the
cosmos throughout the 1930s physicists
realized that starlight must be
generated by nuclear
fusion this is when lighter elements
like hydrogen are bound together by the
strong force into heavier elements
but just how did this work
there were clearly two forces to worry
about
firstly the strong force responsible for
binding the nuclei together but the
strong force only acts over very short
distances two nuclei must essentially
touch for the strong force to latch them
together as the nuclei are composed of
positively charged protons they repel
through electromagnetism for fusion to
work in the sun nuclei must be thrown
together hard enough to overcome the
electromagnetic repulsion and for the
strong force to grab on
but there is
a problem the core of a star is crushed
to incredibly high temperatures by the
weight of the star pressing down
astronomers have calculated a newborn
sun would have a central temperature
approaching 15 million kelvins but at
this temperature the collisions between
protons the nuclei of hydrogen is just
too gentle the electromagnetic repulsion
keeps the protons too far apart for
fusion
so
how could the sun
possibly
shine
and this is where the tiny quantum world
comes in
[Music]
the answer was given by an enigmatic
scientist george gamau born in odessa
when it was part of the russian empire
gamow was a true polymath his mind
roamed from the birth of the universe
through radioactivity and into how dna
stored information
but for our story it is gamma's insight
into quantum mechanics that matters he
realized that we cannot treat colliding
nuclei like solid balls of matter due to
heisenberg's uncertainty principle at
the quantum level everything is fuzzy
when two nuclei collide they are not
simply a certain distance apart they are
many distances apart
instantaneously
and somewhere in this fuzzy mix they
might be close enough for the strong
force to do its work
through quantum uncertainty the two
nuclei overcome the barrier of
electromagnetic repulsion allowing them
to fuse and release their nuclear energy
this tunnelling through such seemingly
impenetrable barriers is a feature of
the quantum world
and it is this
that allows the sun
to shine
following these revelations throughout
the 40s and 50s astronomers steadily
uncovered the secret lives of stars
spurred on by the surge in nuclear
research throughout the second world war
they pieced together the complex web of
nuclear burning firstly from simple
hydrogen into helium then helium into
beryllium and carbon and then onto
heavier elements
but even with the help of quantum
physics nuclear reactions are fickle
very massive stars are needed to create
heavier elements from carbon and oxygen
and up to iron it is only in their cores
crushed to immense temperatures and
density by their weight can the extreme
conditions needed for this nuclear
burning occur
these elements are essential for our
existence in the universe but of course
they are useless locked away buried deep
within stars
it is only at the end of a star's life
that elements can be released
and just as the seemingly tiny
macroscopically irrelevant world of
quantum mechanics gives them light
it can propel these elements into the
cosmos
in spectacular fashion
the neutrino is a curious particle with
virtually no mass and no charge and so
is invisible to all electric and
magnetic fields it is also blind to the
strong force that binds the nuclei of
atoms together
in fact neutrinos only feel the weak
force the strangest of all the
fundamental quantum forces
posited by wolfgang paulie in the 1930s
due to their incredible elusiveness it
wouldn't be another 25 years until
neutrinos were finally captured in an
experiment this is because with only
quantum weak force interactions the
neutrino simply ignores most matter it
will happily travel through a light year
of lead before there is a chance of it
interacting with a single atom
and yet they play a crucial role in
supernovae
the death
of massive stars
in the immense crush of a collapsing
giant star electrons are forced into
protons and this radioactive decay spits
out neutrinos
huge numbers of neutrinos try to escape
the star but finding themselves in a
super dense environment they slam into
the in-falling layers and by sheer
numbers they reverse the collapse
and rip the star apart
spewing the diverse elements back
into the cosmos
clearly quantum physics is written into
the operation of the universe
through its role in generating solar
heat or recycling elements across the
cosmos it is essential for our every
existence
but it doesn't stop there
could quantum physics play an even
larger role
do we only need to think about the
quantum nature of the extremely tiny
or is there a bigger question we should
be asking
is
the entire universe
a quantum
object
in quantum physics the wave function
encapsulates all the information in an
object but two individual objects are
not described by two individual wave
functions instead we use a single wave
function to encompass both in fact in
quantum theory we can use a single wave
function to describe any number of
particles
this raises a huge question one of the
biggest possible
could we write down a single wave
function to account for the quantum
state
of the entire universe
a wave function to account for every
particle of matter and photon of light
it would be truly immense
but at the very least
theoretically possible
consider the world of classical physics
imagine you could know the precise
location and speed of every atom and
photon at a particular instant
impractical but possible in theory with
this information you could use the laws
of physics to calculate where every
particle will be in the future this is
because classical physics is
deterministic and with it the universe
ticks like clockwork
the future is completely written into
the fabric of today
quantum physics on the other hand is
built
on probabilities
knowing the wave function today will
tell me the wave function tomorrow but
not a single definite tomorrow
a whole host of possible
tomorrows
which of these follows the true future
path of the universe
physicists
are unsure
and in the 1950s hugh everett iii
proposed a radical solution
in his many worlds viewpoint he decided
that there was no single future for the
universe out there in this multiverse of
universes there are other versions of
you in some universes you may have won
the lottery in others you may be a rock
star or a famous actor
and of course in some
you are absolutely identical
everett's ideas were too radical for the
time and unappreciated he eventually
left science
but the notion of a wave function for
the entire universe did not leave with
him
even stephen hawking pondered whether a
quantum universe could solve one of the
great mysteries
namely whether the universe had a
beginning
working with jim hartel he deduced that
in the early universe the quantum nature
of time was indistinct
with this time only really came into
existence when the universe became more
distinct
the singularity that dogged classical
cosmology written in relativity just
didn't occur
because there was no real time when it
could have
as you can imagine not everyone is happy
with this picture and debate continues
to rage
and indeed that is far from the only way
quantum physics has been implicated in
the beginning of our universe
to find out more we must travel back in
time
back
to the first trillionth of a second
of existence
in the 1970s physicist alan guth had a
problem
he had something he needed to hide
magnetic monopoles they are the magnetic
equivalent of electric charges and like
electric charges which can be positive
or negative these monopoles would be
purely north
or south
but this should strike you as strange
every magnet you played with at school
always had both a north and a south
you never get just a north or just the
south
so why was gouth thinking about them
and why
did he need
to hide them
guth was and is a cosmologist and was
thinking about the very early universe
in its super hot super dense state many
physicists thought that the laws of
physics should be simpler instead of
there being four distinct fundamental
forces theories suggested that there was
one super force
as the universe cooled and expanded the
super force fractured into the current
forces within this super force there
should be no distinction between
electricity and magnetism
with electric charges there should also
be magnetic monopoles
but whilst there is copious electric
charge in the universe there appeared to
be no monopoles
if this super force picture was correct
these magnetic monopoles
needed to be hidden and it was 1981 when
guth hit upon an intriguing solution
what if the universe underwent a rapid
burst of expansion when it was very
young
this rapid inflation of the universe
would dilute the number of monopoles and
with perhaps one monopole in the entire
observable universe they would be
undetectable
looking at his equations guth saw that
this inflation could explain some other
features of the universe
firstly why it appears to be so smooth
when we look at the universe on large
scales millions to billions of light
years it appears to be the same
everywhere why should this be the case
just to random fluctuations some regions
should be more dense others less
guth realized that his inflation blew up
a tiny chunk of space to the size of the
universe around us and as this tiny
chunk was so small it would have been
quite smooth
and its smoothness gives us the
smoothness of the heavens
and this again is where the quantum
world raises its head
this initial chunk of smooth space would
still have hosted a quantum vacuum
within it heisenberg's uncertainty would
still have brought energy and matter in
and out of existence
and when the universe inflated these
minuscule fluctuations would have been
frozen into space
as inflation ends its energy is dumped
back into the universe as matter and
radiation and the frozen quantum
fluctuations would result in slightly
more matter in one place than another
these differences were tiny less than
one part in a billion but as the fires
of the cosmic birth dimmed gravity
started to play its part
tiny over densities began to draw in
mata from their surroundings clumps of
matter and gas began to pool until a few
hundred million years after the big bang
they were dense enough to form the first
stars
quantum fluctuations frozen into the
universe at inflation became the seeds
of galaxies today
and we still see them in all their glory
written into the ancient light of the
cosmic microwave background
in this theory the quantum world has
shaped our cosmos
but there is
one step further
back to go
[Music]
could we use quantum mechanics to
confront the ultimate question of where
our universe
actually came from
the year is 1973 and young physicist
edward tryon is watching a lecture by
dennis charmer considered one of the
fathers of modern cosmology
there is a pause in the lecture and
suddenly without prompt edward hears
himself speaking
maybe the universe
is a vacuum
fluctuation
there is a murmur of laughter in the
room and siama continues his lecture
but tryon
wasn't joking
and in december 1973 he published a
paper with almost that exact title
is the universe a vacuum fluctuation
trion was trying to unpack the bizarre
implications of the quantum vacuum how
the energy in a vacuum can fluctuate
over time very briefly breaking the law
of conservation of energy
and it was this that led him to wonder
what the total energy content of the
universe was
clearly all the mass and motion would be
an immense quantity of energy
but there is also the potential in
gravitational and other fields and this
potential energy is negative
so he thought if you sum up all the
energy in the universe
perhaps they balance
and perhaps
the total
is zero
staring at heisenberg's uncertainty
principle tryon realized a fluctuation
of zero energy
could last
forever
perhaps the entire universe
was just a quantum fluctuation
of course this raises the immediate
question of where did this fluctuation
occur
which would just leave us back
at the start
where did the quantum fields come from
what
came before them
we now know in our quantum universe it
is possible to draw something from
nothing
but what could happen inside a true
nothing outside of time and space still
remains a question beyond the borders of
science
despite this though we can't speak with
certainty of what happened before it is
clear that within the first tiny moments
of existence quantum mechanics
inevitably played a role
but what about the very end of time
could the distant unimaginably vastly
universe 2
be shaped
by the quantum
when the universe was young and
energetic it made stars in abundance
half the stars that will ever exist were
created in the first few billion years
over the last nine billion years almost
all the remainder were created and as
the universe ages its ability to create
stars is rapidly diminishing in the
future only the final five percent of
stars will be born
[Music]
but as we have seen
stars don't live forever
massive stars live for millions of years
stars like the sun can last for billions
in time only the puniest of stars feeble
red dwarfs will exist
these tiny stars burn through their
nuclear fuel extremely smoothly they can
live for tens of trillions of years
but eventually even their nuclear fires
are extinguished and they die
all that will exist will be a dark husk
slowly losing its heat into the dying
cosmos
of course the forces still operate and
gravity will continue to squeeze and
squeeze
and without the steady flow of nuclear
energy you might expect that gravity
would crush the dead star out of
existence
but something stops this seemingly
inevitable collapse
and again heisenberg's uncertainty
principle is the source
as the star cools and loses its energy
in its heart gravity squeezes electrons
and protons closer together for any
individual electron the room in which it
can jiggle about gets smaller and
smaller in terms of quantum physics the
electron is being constrained to a tiny
volume and this means our knowledge of
the electron's speed becomes larger and
larger even at a temperature of absolute
zero quantum mechanics ensures the
electrons keep jiggling
meaning the electrons now have a quantum
pressure known as degeneracy pressure
that halts the gravitational collapse
and so the dead stars sit there in the
darkness
for eternity
but not quite
on immense time scales the question
arises about the very stability of
matter
whilst protons seem eternal there are
hints that they are not
some scientists think that other
undetected forces might exist hidden in
the universe on time scales of 10 to the
power of 36 years their presence could
become apparent the action of these
forces could cause protons to
disintegrate into simpler particles
and so finally the matter in dead stars
would simply melt
into darkness
once they are gone only black holes
remain
on the face of it being just distortions
in time and space these might seem
impervious
but quantum physics ensures their time
is also limited the culprit again is
heisenberg's uncertainty principle in
particular the fluctuation of energy in
apparently empty space
it was stephen hawking who first
realized that the quantum vacuum spelt
doom for black holes the mathematics of
the quantum vacuum is quite complex it
can be envisaged as fluctuations in the
quantum fields of all particles and
anti-particles together one particularly
strange aspect is that whilst the waves
of particles are moving forwards in time
the waves of their anti-particles
are moving backwards
in a random chunk of vacuum these waves
almost cancel but near a black hole
is not a random chunk of vacuum
its presence where you can fall in but
it is impossible to escape
firmly separates the past and future
and this disrupts the state of the
quantum waves in the vacuum
some of the fluctuating fields are no
longer cancelled
with this the virtual particles become
real particles tapping into the energy
of the black hole as the particles flow
away
the black hole steadily evaporates
it is here we seem to reach the end of
our cosmic journey
but is there more
to tell
in 1958 physics was a buzz
rumors were swirling about a theory of
everything
this theory would unite quantum physics
with einstein's gravity under a single
mathematical umbrella physicists had
known for decades that the language of
curved space-time and the probabilities
of quantum mechanics was simply
incompatible a theory of everything
could open new doors on the universe
the proposers of this theory heisenberg
and paulie were giants of quantum
physics
they were now part of the old guard
rather than the young men who had
discovered neutrinos and created the
principle of uncertainty
but maybe just maybe together they had
scenes through the mathematical fog and
cracked the problem
paulie was invited to speak on this new
theory at columbia university
a group of physicists travelled from
princeton to hear the great man explain
his ideas
but as the lecture unfolded everyone in
the room realized it was a lost course
the idea that all particles are actually
different guises of a single truly
fundamental particle
could not be correct
freeman dyson said it was like watching
the death
of a noble animal
indeed many great physicists have been
obsessed by a theory of everything
einstein was excited when theodore
kaluza added electromagnetism to his
general theory of relativity but the
excitement waned as it was realized that
including quantum mechanics was fraught
nevertheless einstein didn't give up
with multiple attempts to derive a
theory of everything before his death in
1955
of his attempts he wrote most of my
intellectual offspring end up very young
in the graveyard of disappointed hopes
this search continues today and
strangely it is frustrated by scientific
success
einstein's general relativity remains
the most accurate description of gravity
your gps is testament to this
and for the other forces the strong weak
and electromagnetism quantum physics is
all that is required this too is an
amazingly successful theory within its
modern form known as quantum field
theory quarks are ripples in the quark
field photons are ripples in the photon
field and electrons are ripples in the
electron field
the mathematics of quantum field theory
accurately tells us the probabilities of
how particles interact and what is
precisely seen in the particles spewed
from the collisions of the large hadron
collider but fundamentally the
mathematics of relativity and quantum
mechanics are simply incompatible in
their current form they refuse to work
together
a new theory with new mathematics is
essential
physicists have therefore found
themselves in a theoretical playground
without experimental clues to guide them
which has of course led to an explosion
of ideas perhaps the world is ultimately
made of strings whose vibrations dictate
that they are quarks or electrons
perhaps loop quantum gravity is correct
with the universe knitting itself with
threads of space and time perhaps we are
fundamentally membranes floating in an
11-dimensional sea
or perhaps
none of these is the true path to
enlightenment
our century-old search for the theory
continues and we have no idea when it
will end
but let's
pretend
let's imagine that we have our theory of
everything gravity and quantum physics
written in a single language
what secrets of the universe
would it reveal
the first place we will look is into
black holes
with only general relativity all the
mass in a black hole is squeezed into a
single point of infinite density and
infinities really have no place in
physical theories the hope is that
within the theory of everything this
infinity never occurs prevented by the
action of the quantum
and there is another infinity that dogs
einstein's relativity
the infinity at the birth
of the universe
at the moment of creation the cosmic
density was infinite and it is this
infinity that stops us from peering
before
the big bang
it stops us from knowing where our
universe ultimately came from
it stops us from knowing
what came before
hopefully the theory of everything will
open this locked door perhaps it will
reveal that we were born from a previous
incarnation a universe before our own
perhaps we will find that we are lost in
the multiverse just one universe of
countless others
or perhaps we will pry open the door to
find ourselves staring into an abyss
an aberration born from a random
fluctuation
our existence little more than a quantum
dream against a backdrop
of unending nothingness
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching i will see you next
time
[Music]
you